welcome to cloud on air these are live
webinars commit to you every Tuesday
from Google cloud my name is Pete
Rosella I'm a developer advocate for
Google Analytics in data studio and I'm
in house cozy a developer advocate for
data studio and we'll be talking about
building dashboards for NCAA March
Madness
so get so many questions during the
session the platform can accept those
questions and we have a Googler on
standby to answer them and they'll also
do a session at the end to answer any
questions you might have so with that
let's get started so before we go into a
presentation let's think about why
visual up I hope in today's world we get
a lot of data for a lot of different
places we're collecting data we're
looking at them analyzing them so people
at different places and different
positions will have to use this you know
to get insights you can be an individual
scientist you can be someone working in
an organization and you can use this
data to get insights analyze the data
and also verify any findings that you
might have data visualization gives you
a easy way to look at the data and get
insights very quickly you can have to
specialize in it and you don't have to
it's a very low barrier to entry and
there are tools out there that will let
you quickly get into the data look at a
lot of data as an overview as a whole
then quickly zoom in filter and then get
insights from there yeah I think it's a
good point also it maybe communicate
around how that data like how the data
looks how it potentially might provide
some insights to other people within the
company or people you might work with so
really a really great way to communicate
a message of people is also through
visualization of data to really help
them understand maybe some key points of
something you're trying to communicate
so it's a really powerful tool exactly
so when you're analyzing data you can
either do it exploit your analysis our
explanatory analysis and when you're
doing the explanatory analysis you're
basically taking your findings and
sharing with other people in through
different medium so you can take data
from a lot of different sources and one
of the interesting sources that you have
is sports in different sports you can
get data from data about different
things in this course and they look at
it and analyze it so recently last year
Google Cloud B the partnership with NCAA
where Google cloud became leave off
shall publish cloud provider for NCAA
you can find more information about this
partnership on the cloud portal if you
go to this link this will show you
different news about the partnership how
NCAA is using the cloud infrastructure
and cloud services to analyze the data
getting insights and implementing those
and also there is a NCAA data set
available in the Google bigquery so this
link will take us to that data set this
data set basically has NCAA game data
for play-by-play data going back to 2009
and before that you have final scores
back to 1986 and additional wins data
about wins and losses going back to even
1894 so when you talk about like say I
play this is like each event that's
happening like on the court for these
games exact specific data these are very
detailed data about every even that goes
goes on in the game we can have a brief
look at the data set
sure this opens up bigquery and you can
see there are a lot of tables in here so
one table that will be looking into
using guest you later is this one and
this table alone has more than 24
million rows okay so it's a lot of data
this seems like somewhat complicated I
guess maybe it's around like there's
something we want to visualize might be
maybe students gonna help with making
this a little bit easier to work with
right yes that's why this will come in
that it will make all of these
complicated and detailed Big Data make
it easier to understand and easier to
use and get insights from Yax I think
there's a there's a wide range of
people's skills and abilities around
working with data and I think bigquery
is very advanced and very specifically
powerful to do a lot of things with it
can definitely be a little over waiting
for new people I think in the data so
you can really help make this much
easier around terms of developing and
and exploring the data in a much easier
way but super powerful tool if you're
familiar with the query it's great
alright so you've looked at the data set
a bit now the way to analyze this data
is use data studio data studio is
Google's next-generation business
intelligence and visualization tool it's
we free you can go to data studio Google
comm and start using the tool right now
it connects to a lot of different Google
services and lets you analyze the data
that that's available to you so we use
say the studio to analyze some of these
nca data sets that we have this is one
of those - for so we'll look at it right
now
this opens up the dashboard and this is
pulling in data from bigquery as we
speak so this is live right this is life
this shows you how like bigquery in
terms have been able to crunch a lot of
data very quickly so this is like 24
million yes so later so since I clicked
and till the moment this dashboard
became available data studio worked with
bigquery to go through all those 24
million records and get the summer
summary and then bring up this dashboard
that's pretty impressive and this is
like a total aggregate view of all the
data we have like 174 thousand field
goals made yes Mandor doesn't feel so
it's a lot okay so there's a lot of
events that are happening and you can
interact with the dashboard right now so
let's say we want to look at a certain
game we don't look at want to look at
all the games just pick one and this
will list this will list all the games
and this is something that happened
yesterday Florida State versus Xavier so
let's look at that one if we click on
this it will filter the view for only
for that game and we can see all the
shots that were made during that game
the red ones are the shots that made but
didn't score and the green ones are the
shots that did score you can also use
other filters let's say if we pick only
the three-point shots this will keep
only the shots that are outside of it
you should only see you should only see
dots around the outside okay great and
we can go back and keep all of them we
can pick a different game so let's pick
something you can filter something Rhode
Island versus Steve let's pick this one
okay so it's again going called the data
set trying to filter and this is the
filtered view you can concentrate a
filter by date since we picked only one
game is showing the filter for that one
it looks like you have like additional
data when you hover over each one of
these dots like do you get some
additional information so it when you're
hovering over a point it will give you
the details of that record for example
this one was a even where Darren Russell
made a three-point jump shot
the shot made because shot was made it
was true and it happened at the 731 mark
of the game that's cool you can also
look at each team you can filter only
for let's say Rhode Island in this game
and this shows us all the shots that
Rhode Island made during this game so
yeah this is one view of the dashboard
and we can look at a second dashboard
that we have if we go back this is now
the dashboard in data studio but this is
going from a different data set again
this is like live data coming directly
from the bigquery like that data set
that was a big query yeah exactly
it's crunching all the data and this is
a comparison view between two teams you
can pick any team you want on the left
side and on the right side and it will
give you a summary of the all summary
summary of all the data for that team
for the 2017 to tweet in season okay for
example for North Carolina you can see
they have three six wins and novan
losses compared to UCLA we have 21 wins
and twelve losses on this side and this
side you can see all the games that be
this these teams played and the scores
who they played it with and the scores
of each game we should see about 11
losses and three six wins for North
Korea on this side and there are other
stats
related to all of these games for both
of these teams and you can pick a
different team from here as well sure
and this so this goes back to your
original when you were talking about
visualization visualization of data
being able to in a quick glance get some
insights out of data because we have
this huge data table this huge data set
in bigquery you know with the report
that you're able to create this one's a
somewhat complicated report it looks
like it was a lot of work I don't know
maybe it wasn't but well I'm gonna go
through some demos later but you know in
a quick glance you can get some good
insights in view of this data and that's
the power of visualization right so
alright this is a very I think for
people who are basketball fans probably
somewhat similar view but again like a
it is a visualization that you're
creating here to represent this huge set
of data right right very intersting this
is cool so we didn't see like people are
maybe North Carolina's got a good way
record versus maybe Michigan has a great
home record so something quick insights
you can get just by yes that's the whole
idea that yeah if you wanted to get
these kind of insights from the data raw
data set you'd have to write a lot
queries and maybe death those wouldn't
give you this whole complete holistic
picture at one glance you'd have to
write different queries at different
time just get one simple point of data
and for if you wanted a different team
you'd have to pick a different query
again and that would take a lot of time
but once you have this completed
solution that you design this gives you
an overview and you can design it for
one team and then you can simply switch
the view and look at the same
information for other teams as well and
you can do quick comparisons now we've
seen some examples of the dashboards and
we'll see you later how we can build
them but let's talk a little bit about
data studio as I mentioned earlier data
studio is the next generation business
ingredients and visualization tool from
Google it's completely free you can use
it right now by going to data studio
cool calm the way data studio works is
that first you connect to your data then
you try to visualize your data and then
you while you're visualizing you can set
it up here for exploratory analysis or
you can also do exponential where you're
sort of trying to share it with other
people and once that is ready you
basically set up your dashboard so that
other people can view your work so let's
go through these steps one by one when
we're connecting when you're connecting
to your data in data studio you have
lots of options available you have a lot
of connectors you can connect to
internal Google Google data sources like
sheets B query cloud sequel and cloud
storage your data might be already
present there or your data might be
outside of these sources and you can
bring in your data from your on-premise
data source or external source and bring
those data into these sources you can
also bring in your existing information
from Google Analytics Adwords YouTube we
have direct direct connectors available
for this you might also have on-premise
data in my sequel or Postgres and data
studio can connect to connect directly
to those data sources to those databases
and bring the data into Data sphere for
you to analyze now these are mostly
internal these are mostly Google data
sources but what if your data is
somewhere else what is what if you have
to access your data using a public API
or you have on-premise data that you can
access using a private API that's where
community connectors come in committee
characters are connectors for data view
that are designed by the studio
community they let you
get your data from any any API that
might be include Web API or JDBC and
bring that data into Data studio for you
to analyze yeah it's a very powerful
feature we've seen a lot of people using
this feature to bring in data that's not
necessarily publicly available maybe
it's something just for your company
that you might have a specific API and
you really want to be able to allow your
users within your company analyze that
data within data studio so this really
gives you a great option to extend the
platform and bring the data that's
really important to your business or to
you know to specifically to some use
case that you might have and we've seen
it we haven't you have a lot built by
our partners already that are supported
by your partners but we've definitely
seen a lot of growth around just
companies building their own connectors
to make the to make me do a use case and
examine yeah it's been it's been really
a large number credibility has been
great yeah we have I believe we have
around 75 kind of cars that connect to
more than 400 data sources area now I
mean the data is the most important part
of it right to start with right without
the data you can't do any analysis
obviously go to stats this is the
biggest component right neither
everybody has access to lots of data
they're not sara lee easy to get to
sometimes but this makes it much much
simpler and this gives you the
flexibility to have your customized
solution you can bring in templates that
work with your community connectors and
provide you with a very customized
solution either for your clients or for
your customers or even for your internal
employees so we got the data and so we
have the data but then you can create
visualized once you have bring brought
your data into a de studio you can
create some nice visualizations and
we'll see how you can build those
visualizations so see you're visualizing
is already built and now you want to
share your work with others how how can
you do that there are multiple ways
available the first is you can just
share with a link just like drive or
just like drive documents you can
provide people with view access or write
access you can also embed your days to
do report as a
infographic or report in any web page or
you can use it as a presentation well
have a very quick look at one of these
examples this is a blog post on the
cloud big data blog where there was an
analysis of the box in data for Bitcoin
and over here you can see
there are data studio dashboards that
are working on live data and you can
interact with these dashboards right now
we can pick a date range let's say we
can pay so this is on the Google cloud
blog and it's an embedded dashboard in
the blog so if anybody went to this URL
right now they would see this reporter
they could actually interact with it
correct exactly and this was made using
data studio using the big grey data and
using bigquery data now going back so
let's create some dashboards we've seen
we know how data studio works so let's
use that knowledge to use let's use that
knowledge to create some definition we
use but let's try with a very simple
example first look at a sheet that has
some data so this Google sheet has data
from fuel economy gov it's a subset of
the data that contains fuel economy
about different vehicles this is what
the data looks like so this is just
giving an overview of like end to end
how this how the future actually works
in product works so we have some data
we're going to start with in this case
just the fuel data rates fuel and we can
go data studio so this the sheet it's in
Google sheets there's a sheet of data
right there coming into the day studio
and then they're picking let's say I'll
be create a new report so but to create
a new report is creating my new report
and I'll create a new data source and
I'll peak and the data source is like a
connection to some some data somewhere
right so like in this case we're going
to connect to Google sheets and create
this data source right these connectors
are the characters do they dimension
record that they said different data
sources are that you can connect to yes
so pick sheets and this is the sheet
that we're trying to connect you it will
give us a list of the worksheets and
we're going to connect to the data
worksheet does this one yeah and now
this they just be when two went into the
sheet and tried to figure out what data
is there and I know that this one is due
it's a number I want to use it as a txt
and so I'll just change this type to
text and I'll do a quick count on the
number of this and then I'll add it to
the report okay so this just represents
all the different columns that were in
the sheet that's
different fields that you can work with
okay so let's say I want to look at all
the vehicles that were added to the
database and the date of the vehicle
release date of the vehicle so I will
add the count of vehicles as matric that
we're trying to use and also we'll make
it a cumulative number so we can say
that it's about 1200 so we'll also put
the total number in here so we pick the
line chart here which is a time series
chart but we'll pick a total score card
that will look at the same information
but at a aggregate level so for this one
I'll pick again the distinct count so
1220 our records are there and as you
can see it's a very nice easy to use
flexible interface where you can do drag
and drop
we can also create a bar chart and we
want to look at different air aspiration
method and maybe look at their average
mileage and make it a present or bar
chart so we've taken that sheet that was
you know columns of data and be able to
visualize it very easily with click
point drag and drop different components
of visualizations that we have right
very very simple process and this is
where we're trying to do a maybe look at
the percentage of vehicles that are
marked as gas guzzler okay and we'll do
one more example here that says quick
scatter chart
we'll pick maybe the record number here
and we will do engine displacement and
the mileage so this gives us a nice
scatter chart of all the vehicles and
their mileage versus engine displacement
you can also set up different colors
different label using different colors
maybe we will change the color to
represent the aspiration method of the
engine and now you can see a nice
scatter chart that shows the
relationship between the mileage and
displacement that this gives us a quick
overview of the capabilities of data
studio so let's go back and try to use
what we learned here to create some
dashboards using the nca data so first
we will try to create the dashboard from
the NCAA play-by-play data we've already
created a data source using the bigquery
connector and we'll just use that so the
status source is connecting to that
table you showed us in bigquery earlier
so there's there's that that we made the
connection the data source is already
created and now we can just use that
data source we've already done and this
data source can be using multiple
reports right now yes this one so if you
can reuse them basically yeah if you
create the data source once you can just
keep on using it multiple times and
across different sources and you don't
have to reconfigure it here so you
create a scatter chart now how did you
know like what fields are in your hair
and like which ones to do did you do so
we spent some times we had to spend some
time with it is it to figure out which
field was what and we built it once but
at least we have some idea so add a
small filter that says exclude shops
made so excluding shots made what for
what for what research we're exhuming
shot type shot type so there are lots of
events in this data the short type means
that if the short type is now then it
shot wasn't made so we're only trying to
look at events that where a shot was
tried to like a shot was tried someone
tried to get a scope yeah so it's um
it's always important to like look at
your data understand what is in that
data like what thing what questions are
trying to answer and maybe maybe there's
some some things you need to you know
filter out or clean up just to get your
data prepared in a spot that's good for
you to start visualizing right exactly
yeah
and we know that there are coordinates
for the course so these corneas
represent the coordinate of the court so
we'll put those coordinates here so with
the x coordinate for the X metric and
the y coordinate for the Y matrix this
is a scatter pot you said write a
scatter plot we starting to take some
shape
and they filter for just one game so
let's add this filter and this filter
will let us choose a game values and we
want to just pick one game so let's see
what game we can pick from here you can
view the report we can see there are
different games over here and we'll try
to let's say pick the penn state versus
pittsburgh one to copy this value go
back and say that this is the value we
want to be selected by default by
default okay and you just drag that
filter on and it lists everything for
you automatically based on that that
dimension that you already selected
right yes dimension is going into the
data data set and trying to see what
values are there all the unique values
in spilling that up and populating the
control over there yeah and for this one
we'll try to also break down the data by
first let's say timestamp
and then my event and the event is the
so time tip tops at the time that this
event happened and the event is a
description of what type of event it was
yes okay and this shot type and we want
to know the shot type yep and we try to
do this average because there might be
same things everything over time and so
like within the product itself you could
actually change the aggregation type of
these different metrics by clicking that
little a little a little yes so what I'm
doing here is I'm going here and I'm
changing if the numbers are getting
aggregated how are the numbers getting
aggregated and we can see it there's
some kind of pattern coming up here
we'll add the image of the court over
here
so I'll add an image I'll select a file
I already have to just have a level over
here so the course is completely
available
image yes yes we just spend some time
making it earlier and we'll bring this
one to the front and we'll try to make
this look nicer so we'll get rid of we
know that the bounds for these axes are
on the y-axis it's 600 and on the x-axis
its 1100 so we'll hide the axis we'll
also hide the legend and this is
starting to look like the code that we
just created and if we reshape it you
can see what's going on here
sure we can also change the colors to
show whether the shot was made or not we
can do
[Music]
what's the what you're looking for here
the so I'm trying to see whether the
shots result in a goal or a score or not
okay so show like it's true or false
kind of thing if it's gait or not and
not to determine the color of the actual
dot itself I guess if I go back in and
choose this shot made and will change
the colors if the shot was made we'll
make it green and if it was not made
it's already red and this is basically
what the game looked like okay so this
is one data one visualization that we
can recreate and we can see right now
that we can pick different games from
here we can pick this one and that'll
update the whole score card the whole
visualization to reflect the outcome of
that game particularly sure so a couple
things to note here I guess one is the
filter was added and it automatically
worked with that visualization right so
there's some kind of magic going on
there that's assuming that these two
things are related together and if they
work together you know you get this
result which is great another thing is I
think you were able to build a
visualization actually fairly quickly
given like it looked like it was a very
complicated visualization you see the
new node what to do very well very
quickly right so it seems like you spend
some with the data beforehand right so
yeah it really you do understand that
data you're working with understand the
date of that and you know dig in a
little bit and just understand kind of
the questions you're trying to answer
which makes it you know we were able to
do fairly quickly but I think it shows
really the capability of being able to
visualize things quickly it's definitely
possible right and the other thing is
you can also use J's to do to look at
the data itself so you can do quick
aggregations you can look at different
histograms and I figure out what what
does this field mean how does this
column really to this other column so
the estudio can be your expiry tool as
well so that was one dashboard that we
looked at and then let's try to create a
second dashboard which is the team's
game data okay and again we have the
data source ready for this and we use
this data source to create the dashboard
now this one had a lot going on right
there was a lot of different components
that were going yes and we'll try to
create some components for there sure so
let's create a report is this the same
data - is the same table that we have a
different table or a different table
that has information about the team's
doesn't have to play-by-play information
so the first thing we'll do is we'll add
a filter over here and pick a team so if
I type team here or we're trying to look
at separate difference if you want to
see team by team comparison things okay
yes oh and I know that I by default I
want to look at Duke okay and I'll add a
table and I want to see all the games
they have played so I'll add those games
one by one so look at the game so gonna
have things like the game the game name
some other some attributes of the game
you want to know it's gonna show up on
this table it's autumn I think it'd be
filtered by that control you put on
there already I was just great school
he's already there so the game score is
already there and we'll bring in the
element name okay so who they're playing
that's important it'll be useful to know
and let's see if we can bring out the
date
and we'll try to sort by the date so as
you can see this this gives us the dates
for all like this bit of information for
all of the games across different
seasons and we'll see a little bit later
how we can filter only for the current
season sure this goes back like years
right so there's lots of data here you
up to 2009 so this one is here and we
can see the last game they played was in
March 17 like a few days ago and there
was it was a good win when they scored
87 verse against Rhode Island
sure so we'll just group these two so
that this filter is applied only to this
table so when you select those these two
and you can scrub the filtering down
just to one particular table yeah so you
can have figures at multiple hierarchies
you can set filters at page level at
report level I also add a different
element level within the same page sure
and we'll make a copy of this and paste
the same thing and let's see for this
one we want to look at only Virginia
so we now have a comparison between Duke
and virgin on the same page now let's
add a page level filter that will try to
give us data for a specific season so
I'll try to find this season so we have
two identical
I mean you copy the one you change the
filter in the one and now you're
creating another feltit just give me the
whole page it's out of control
yes higher level okay so we can see that
the Duke has played we have been version
4 over 4 182 games of Duke and hundred
seventy-six game from Virginia but let's
limit that to only that current 2017
season so pick 2017 over here and that
should limit everything down only up to
the this year and you can see that this
year they played 35 games Duke and
working up late 34 games and this
dashboard is right now ready to be
viewed so we can also pick different
years from here you can take different
teams if you can't play let's say Santa
Cruz and you can see the game
information there only one gave me over
here at all and this this report can be
shared with anybody yes it can also be
embedded in a web site or blog exactness
if you want to show you someone you can
just click this button and you can share
it with someone else you can get a
shareable link where other people can
use this building directly to view the
report or you can use also shared with
specific people give them either edit
access our view access and if you want
to embed it go back to the dashboard
what we have here is you can go to file
embed report you enable embedding and
this gives you a nice little code
snippet you can just copy and paste it
into any website that supports embedding
iframe in meeting and then you'll be
able to view and interact with this
dashboard within that website so we
built - - what we've seen how their
studio works there are some other
examples we have maybe we can go through
one or two of them right now these are
built by some of our partners or some of
the data enthusiasts we have that have
been using a studio this one is very
interesting this one shows log usage in
DCP the Google crud project a Google
cloud platform where you can see you say
of daily view monthly view and it's
broken down by different services you
can go into this you can filter the data
this is already created and the good
thing is you can take this template and
use it with your own project you don't
have to create this from scratch that's
one of the unique thing very nice things
about data studio is that anytime you
create something you can let other
people you take the template and build
on top of your work you can make a copy
of this and then connect to your own
data source and then all nice work with
your own data exactly this is all of the
fields and things will be the same yeah
as long as the you're using is similar
um similar data set that has the same
field names and structure yeah we're -
there should work there's one other data
set this was made by maksim as one of
our partners this is a economical data
about US household income distribution
by state over here you can see the
income institution for each different
state sort of arranging a geographic
location wise you can see the income
distribution of the East Side west side
and sort of very nice overall view that
gives you a complete picture of the
whole economy in market it's a nice work
here you have like the the
representation of United States of
America and then individually had these
components that are like showing this
this income distribution exactly so
that's the nice like meta uh view of the
of the country and that particular data
set right it's very cool let's look at
one more this one came up new and this
one shows a new feature that we have
that is pretty cool this is data from
the Google merchandise store and this is
bringing analytics data the nice thing
is it's also cooling in the images so if
you have image URLs in your data set you
can take that image URL and you can
render the image in your data studio
dashboard so for each item in the
analytics data they are basically
pulling in that image and rendering it
in data studio to give a nice view of
that product so there's a machine
example of batteries or we don't have
time with you maybe ok let's go back to
me yep the information is available on
our support site you can see how we can
basically you can anytime you have an
image URL in your data set you can just
take that and
yeah it's great exactly and this one is
a very nice example where the studio was
used to showcase school information
student inferences student information
system data that has school district
matrix you have days enroll how many
students were enrolled different
combination of students the raise the
gender and you can filter here to pick
up different grades this is very helpful
for anyone who is sort of like an
administrator in the school system and
again since this is a general purpose
status dashboard someone else who
someone else who has a similar dataset
can just use this copy it and use it for
their own uses somebody copy it you can
edit it and do anything you want with
every part itself right yeah it's
changed things around you can make
adjustments change the data said you can
see how they actually built the report
quite right it helps kids yeah it's
actually great way to learn about how to
use the product it's some that we've
definitely been trying to push be able
to build more templates really showcase
what's possible with their own data and
it's been working really well for people
exactly so these are the resources that
are available for the essary right now
we would be loved for you to go and go
ahead and build the dashboard in a
studio you can go to data studio at
Google com
if you want some inspiration you can go
to the data studio gallery the apps apps
pod calm where we have dashboards from
different partners available you can
watch some tutorials on YouTube if you
want to develop solutions around data
studio you can go to our deaf site at
developers.google.com slash data studio
where we have information about the
community actors and how you can build
one you can also get support at support
our Google comm slash this video and let
us know what what you build any cool
dashboards or any new cool characters
that you come up with
so thank you guys for listening we are
gonna take a short break for some
question and answers that are coming
we're collecting them right now we'll be
back in a few minutes and we'll answer
those questions for you guys so stay
tuned
you
welcome back we have a few great
questions from you guys so we're gonna
go through them now and hopefully
everybody satisfied at the end so the
first question is where do I go to build
my own data connection how long does it
take to do that so the developer
documentation is available at
developers.google.com slash data studio
what you're looking for is a feature
called community connectors and this the
documentation goes through how to
actually build the connector how it
works from end to end and how to test
and provide some samples we also have a
github repository that gives you some
really great detailed examples of how
this code works and how you can build
them how long does it take to do that
so that really depends on the complexity
of the API you're connecting to
how well you know the service you're
connecting to a lot of the work at least
my personal experience is that when
you're going to work with a new API it's
actually that's what takes a long time
is just learning that I mean yeah like
what how does their service work the
actual like writing of the code for the
connector is fairly straightforward and
I probably expect you would be getting
something up and running within probably
an hour at the very least and then
probably what's going to take more time
over over time it's just really like
finalizing that making sure it's like
working well and testing it if you
intend to provide it to others to use
it's really more around the quality
control there so yeah fairly quickly
probably like 10-15 minutes if you're
really you know you probably if you're
familiar with Apps Script so get
something working so it's actually quite
easy to cool to play with the secretary
is what kinds of new fields or metrics
can it create in data studio so it
provides a feature where you can create
calculated matrix and we have more than
70 different functions that you can use
you can basic depending on what data
you're bringing in you can add different
fields together you can do analytical
functions on them if you go to the
support center there's the whole list of
all the functions available and how you
can use them you can also do some
analytical functions like aggregations
percentages of total and things like
those third question is you mentioned
public assets on bit Creek can you show
how to connect to them from data studio
so on bakery there are public data sets
available for anyone to use to use those
what you have to do is basically go into
bigquery and sort of come up with any
query that you might want to do
you can create a whole table and then
you can go into the SVO we can show that
well if you go to the support sent up we
can actually show that it was a show so
let's go into data studio and we'll try
to add a new report we'll create a new
data source will add bigquery so there's
a big query connector right it's going
to show this is a public data set you'll
have to pick your building project you
can get the free building project that
gives you that lets you use data within
some coder you can pick any public data
set you want if you want let's say we'll
pick the World Bank health population
and you can pick which table you want to
look into and then if you connect that
whole connect to bigquery and let you
use the data and also we encourage you
to go to the Help Center documentation
this will also explain how to do this
process right the next question is data
studio is free that's great
yes it is if I upload my own data where
does it go
is that storage also free so in most
cases the connection is actually going
directly to the end service so there in
that case we're not actually storing
anything there is some level of caching
just to make for performance reasons but
we actually don't store anything in that
case there are some connectors like the
CSV upload the file upload in that case
yes then what would be storing via that
actual data and there are some limits I
think that there I'd say 2 gigabytes per
person and that in that if you upload
your own CSV file that will get stored
on cloud storage cloud storage yeah
again if you go to the help center
documentation there is a around the file
upload CSV upload there will be it'll
discuss what the limits are and and
where that data is stored otherwise
typically it's coming directly from the
service right the last question we have
is what about non image URLs in data can
I automatically link out to external
sources and pages yes you can do that
right now if you have any URLs or links
in your data you can create a table and
in the table you can mention that this
this field is a link or this field is a
URL you can also use a URL formula you
can look it up on the help site why
don't we show that we got a few minutes
here to show
sure let's see or the baby or the spot
here so we can do it I have to find
where we have to see where we can find a
URL let's say I'll use the sheets kind
of try and make up a URL over here sure
I'll just add a URL field and I'll say
I'll just say HTTP colon slash slash
data studio dot google.com and I will
connect to this data source so let me go
back to sheets and my start one sheets
connector I will connect to the data and
I'll do connect so we have one column
URL there's a URL in the record over
there and so it's a URL okay and I'll
take this as URL so we've identified
this field as being a URL in this case
we get to specify that right yep what we
can also do just to be sure if you don't
want to specify it as a URL over here
but you want to manually create a
formula what you can do is you're a link
and we can say
so we're create a new field called URL
link and there's some functions that we
can use to actually yep we can use a URL
function URL function okay well
basically since we have already
something named URL it's difficult to
use their own let's just we can use just
this and see how we can order with that
there's the idea is you actually of a
field type that's URL and so then data
city will know what to do with that
because it knows it's been identified as
a URL correctly and if I add this so
this is the URL yeah and we can show it
as auto our image if we view it is
linking like and if we click on it it'll
open the link in a new window and that's
how you can link to external sources and
images work in a very similar fashion
you would say it's an image and then
what its data serial note to do with it
and it actually render the image right
so for the image what you do is you do
it the same way but over here instead of
auto you can show it as an image and to
render
and it will run into image yeah right
great well thank you very much guys for
the questions they were great we hope
you enjoyed yourself today we pleasure
talking to you
we hope you learn something and we'll
try checkout data studio but we want us
to stay tuned for the next session we
have its deploy monitor and optimize
developing applications the Google cloud
platform coming right here from
Sunnyvale so thank you very much